hi there steve here today i'm going to
uh you know someone said what do i think
of brexit and trump and stuff so i don't
want to wade into all of that but today
i'm going to talk a little bit about
my learning and a little bit about my
views on
sort of the political situation that we
find ourselves in first of all i had a
ukrainian conversation this morning and
i did so well i'm so happy because i've
been struggling but i've been continuing
my listing and reading but i just notice
that as i read the text on my ipad in
link and then i listen again more of
these words are now clearer to me the
content that i'm
ingesting in my input activities is
becoming clearer and lo and behold today
i just hit it in my one hour
conversation in ukrainian i was
finding the words i was hitting the
right grammar notes and so
it's one of these eureka moments where
you feel all the effort is worth it so
it's to basically prod you people don't
give up keep at it but you need a lot of
input a lot of combination of listening
and reading
and so
this is what i'm doing to learn
ukrainian or to learn other languages
learning languages is not you know the
only thing there is to do in the world
there's so many things that we can learn
on our own if we are and again the three
keys in language learning apply to so
much else in other words motivation or
attitude the amount of time you spend
and then developing that ability to
notice i notice more and more of the
ukrainian as i'm listening and reading
as i notice it starts to stick in my
brain but this is true if you're
learning other things there's so many
things that we can learn on our own so
this makes me think of the whole
political crisis that we now have in the
united states and elsewhere but if i
just look at the united states this
message
from
president trump and others that you know
things have never been so bad it's a
mess i don't know whatever words he uses
carnage disaster and stuff and i'm
saying like okay so where is the
disaster if you look up statistics
for example
if you were to um if you were to google
i can't remember what it was called here
bear with me
one is called uh how
how america spends money a hundred years
in the life of the family budget
and you will find that um
you know in the year uh
well 100 years ago people spent 45
percent of the family budget on food
today
that number is 12
all right
and in a hundred years ago in 1900
people spent
almost 30 percent of their money
on
uh no no sorry
uh so that the 42 in 1900 dropped to 30
in 1950 and today it's 12
the amount that was spent on clothing
in 1900 was like 12 it's now less than 5
so in other words
what this shows is that the the amount
of discretionary income that people has
have has dramatically increased
including in comparison with uh 2003
if we look at how people spend their
money today
uh we will see that people spend
people spend more money now going out to
eat than they do on food at home now
obviously that doesn't apply to all
classes of people and obviously in the
very lowest
fifth or quintile
people spend twenty thirty percent of
their budget on food however overall
americans spend more money going out to
eat than they do at home this didn't
used to be the case this is spending in
2012 people spend five percent on
entertainment five percent on
restaurants
and uh
where are we groceries is seven percent
so they spend more money on
restaurants and entertainment than they
do on groceries today so things can't be
that bad
on the other hand on education they
spend two percent
so you know as i analyze all these
numbers what comes what becomes clear to
me is
that people should spend more money on
education and that the two items that
have become expensive now are housing
and cars people 100 years ago didn't own
cars and were more likely to rent
so there are issues around cars and how
we use the automobile i mean it's
tremendously wasteful something there
has to give and similarly on if everyone
wants to live in the most attractive
cities then the price of housing is
going to keep on going up but maybe with
the advent of the internet and so forth
people will seek and maybe that's
starting to happen seek to live in less
expensive places
uh the other thing of course is health
and education
i mean in the u.s 18
of the gdp is built on health that's
much higher than anywhere else
uh
it seems to me that has to become more
efficient and education here again
the
while the statistics show a very low
level of unemployment in the united
states and there are people say well you
know but there's 90 million people
looking for work but that includes
retired people students uh you know
people who can't work and so forth and
so on but still there are people who
have dropped out of the
workforce there's a certain sense of
of uh
discouragement and yet there's like five
and a half million jobs in the united
states for which there are no takers and
the reason is
that people aren't don't have the skills
to do these jobs so again if we look at
if you go back to uh over 100 years ago
when maybe half of the people worked on
the farm and then say just after the
second world war where a large number of
people worked in factories things change
so we only have three four five percent
people on the farm
and we're going to have fewer people in
factories it doesn't really matter
whether
the factory jobs in the us are displaced
by imports from low-wage countries or by
robots
in
the united states one way or another
those jobs are not coming back
so
but the jobs that are there require
certain skills and in the united states
and probably elsewhere canada you name
it people aren't training themselves for
those jobs another statistic i found by
googling
is that apprenticeships are down
fewer and fewer people want to take you
know apprenticeship type positions to
learn a trade where they're good wages
100 000 plus wages to be had i know at
our sawmill in northern alberta we had
all kinds of trouble finding skilled
trades people why do people not want to
go into apprenticeships because the
prestige of those jobs isn't as high as
getting some college degree in gender
studies and whatever so
uh on the one hand uh trump is saying
we're gonna bring back factory jobs but
it would appear that for whatever reason
people don't consider those jobs to be
prestigious even though they pay well if
you have the right skills so somehow
that needs to be addressed and also we
have this tremendously expensive uh
educational uh sort of infrastructure
uh where you know if i were to try to
learn my languages in college i would
learn less and it would cost me an awful
lot more i've been able to learn
you know seven languages in the last 10
years using link using resources on the
internet
obviously it doesn't apply to everything
it doesn't apply to you know uh
professional trades where you obviously
have to do hands-on training but a lot
of the technology behind these trays
requires a lot of reading and so there's
a lot of it that people can do on their
own to prepare themselves to take a
technical course as it is right now
unfortunately for mr trump a large
percentage of the technical jobs in the
united states are filled by immigrants
because the americans aren't training
themselves in these jobs and he's
catering to a constituency that is
complaining that they want their factory
jobs back
but that they aren't going to get them
back and if they do get them back they
won't be able to compete with other
countries so invest in education
streamline education streamline health
services
and also recognize that in many ways
people do live a lot better today than
they did 50 years ago so when you're
talking about make america great again
which period are you really talking
about and finally i think there's a lot
that people can do on their own we
needn't wait for the president to make
my life great again maybe
individuals need to look at ways in
which they can make their lives better
again so a bit of a ramble around
first of all my sense of euphoria that
my efforts in ukrainian are bearing
fruit and to continue on that i'm going
to do ukrainian for another couple of
weeks then i'm going to go after
polish
and czech
and do a little bit of russian in the
background
and this is my strategy here of working
on four slavic languages at the same
time to see to what extent it helps me
and to what extent it causes
interference
and i am going to be in bratislava in
june
where there's a polyglot conference and
so part of my strategy is to build up my
capability in these slavic languages i
may not have time to get to
slo slovak or slovakian but if i have
the polish in the check i'm sure i'll
understand the slow backs
and then later in june i will visit
lev and ukraine kind of a reward for my
effort into learning ukrainian so there
you have it a bit of a ramble i look
forward to your comments bye for now
[Music]
you